[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum philosophischen
stammtisch in suhl in basel schön sind
sie dabei unser thema heute die
digitalisierung und was sie mit uns
menschen und unserer gesellschaft macht
haben wir wirklich auf dem schirm worauf
es ankommen wird
oder sind wir gerade dabei die
liegestühle auf der titanic um zu
gruppieren ist richard david precht in
seinem neuen buch sagt er heute zu gast
sein wird ja auch immer sitzt das
philosophische updates zum thema der
stunde hier und jetzt das smartphone
unser täglicher begleiter wir lesen news
prüfen den wetterbericht teilen bilder
entscheiden mit freunden kaufen
einbuchen ein hotel
die digitalisierung hat längst unseren
alltag erreicht und durchdringt alle
lebensbereiche
doch das ist erst der anfang des
radikalen wandels in zukunft steigen wir
in selbstfahrende autos bezahlen in
crypto währungen lassen uns chips unter
die haut implantiert und identifizieren
uns durch automatische gesichtserkennung
doch was bedeutet das für uns und unser
zusammenleben
zerstören algorithmen und roboter
millionenfach jobs oder befreit uns
künstliche intelligenz von mühseligen
arbeit und schenkt das raum für mose und
kreativität bedroht das umfassende
sammeln und auswerten von daten unsere
demokratie und meinungsfreiheit oder
können wir dann big data in zukunft
naturkatastrophen verhindern und
krankheiten schneller heilen
konzentriert sich alles kapital in den
händen weniger digital konzerne und
erlangen diese dadurch immer mehr macht
oder erfinden wir dank der
digitalisierung wirtschaftsmodelle in
denen alle teilhaben und profitieren
ja ich bin gespannt auf die diskussionen
haben philosophischen stammtisch mit
unseren gästen heute richard david
precht philosoph katja gentinetta
politik philosophie und harald welt
sozialpsychologe an flachen
sie schreiben in ihrem neuen buch das
wir ganz dringend die reichen umlegen
müssen wenn wir in eine humane zukunft
reisen wollen
entschuldigung das heißt wir könnten es
auch ganz grinst nicht vermasseln
wir geben uns bislang ziemlich viel zu
vermasseln indem wir sehr viele dinge
schleifen lassen wenn in der politik von
der digitalisierung die rede ist dann in
erster linie im technisch ökonomischen
sinne also wir diskutieren darüber ob
wir genug glasfaser kabel in die erde
legen und ob das alles schnell genug
geht und darüber reden wir ganz viel das
ist auch gemeint wenn parteien über
digitalisierung und über zukunft reden
wir denken eigentlich gar nicht darüber
nach dass hier ähnlich wie bei der
ersten industriellen revolution in eine
zeit kommen in der wir komplett neu über
gesellschaft nachdenken müssen weil sich
strukturell unsere ökonomie radikal
verändert und das ist das was ich
bemängeln dass das viel zu wenig
passiert
nun gibt es ja auch wirklich viel kritik
an dieser ganzen digitalisierung ich
frage mich manchmal prozent in etwa jede
innovation wurde ja immer von technik
kritik begleitet wenn wir ein bisschen
zurückdenken
18 35 erste bahnfahrt in deutschland
ganz ganz viele ärzte die gesagt haben
das gibt lungenentzündung das gibt ihren
erkrankungen sind diese kritischen
stimmen einfach so das übliche technik
geplänkel
ich glaube man muss die kritischen
stimmen schon auch ernst nehmen also zum
einen weisen viele von uns ich zähle
mich ein stück weiter zu sucht
erscheinungen auf wie konsultieren
zwanghaft unser smartphone ungefähr 200
mal am tag verbringen ungefähr 50
minuten am tag damit also alles dinge
die stattfinden schlafstörungen
konzentrationsstörungen bei jugendlichen
sprunghaft angestiegen bei den 25
jährigen das sind dinge die man weiß das
aber auch dinge von denen man sagen kann
mit denen kann man umgehen
beziehungsweise man muss selber einen
umgang finden damit aber was mich viel
mehr beschäftigt ist eigentlich auf
welche weise diese geräte und die
tatsache dass wir ständig unser handeln
unser denken unser überlegen und
entscheiden in dieser apparat
erschüttern irgendwann als
persönlichkeit fassbar werden und wir
wissen ja dass am anderen ende diese
persönlichkeit wiederum genau mit dem
gefüttert wird
was wir möchten und wird beginnen uns in
eine selbstbestätigung slip aus dem wir
sehr schwer herauskommen und das ist für
mich eigentlich die eigentliche neuerung
sieht es ja auch so wenig zuversichtlich
ich bin da eigentlich relativ wenig
zuversichtlich ich wollte aber noch mal
schon mal auf eine sache hinweisen die
in solchen diskussionen und auch in
solchen filmbeiträgen immer wieder auf
feiern weil da ist immer von wir die
rede und von einer unausweichlichen
entwicklung also wir fahren dann autonom
wir haben gesichtserkennung und sonstwas
und das problem ist also sind eigentlich
zwei probleme erstens gehöre ich nicht
zu dem wir weil ich der einzige mensch
auf diesem planeten bin der kein
smartphone hat insofern bin ich da gar
nicht integriert aus überzeugung ja
sicher und zum beispiel aus
zeitersparnis also ich habe relativ viel
zu tun aber ich habe mehr zeit als mein
komplettes soziales umfeld und alle
anderen die ich kenne
weil alle sind sozusagen absorbiert
durch diesen dieser geräte aber der
andere punkt ist ja viel interessanter
warum wird denn davon ausgegangen dass
wir autonom fahren dass wir irgendwie im
smarthome leben oder so es ist doch
eigentlich eine gesellschaftliche und
politische frage ob wir als gesellschaft
so leben wollen oder nicht und die frage
wird ja nicht gestellt es wird immer so
getan und das glaube ich eine unfassbar
effiziente reklame der digitalwirtschaft
die da wirksam wird und keiner kommt auf
die idee dass man vielleicht mal die
frage stellen müsste wer bitte möchte
denn ein autonom fahren das auto
wer möchte da drin sitzen wir sind doch
alle erwachsen geworden weil wir nicht
mehr im kinderwagen herum gefahren
werden wollen oder aber sie herr precht
haben ja auch auf der anderen seite wir
müssen die weichen umstellen
ja aber ich weiß nicht ob dieses wir das
gleiche ist wie dieses wir was harald
welzer gerade kritisiert hat also ich
bin vollkommen seiner meinung was daran
geht das dass der dekan valley eine
wunderbare werbemaschine ist die hingeht
und den zukünftigen lauf der welt als
vorgezeichnet beschreibt als eine von
der evolution vorgegebene entwicklung
die dazu führt dass wir uns irgendwann
chips implementieren lassen also wie
das heißt also alle menschen die sich
das leisten können und vielleicht
irgendwann mal alle menschen in der welt
dass es überall gesichtserkennung geben
wird dass mensch und maschine
schnittstellen zu nehmen dass irgendwann
vielleicht sogar die roboter die
weltherrschaft annehmen so und das wird
so als natürliche produktion
vorgezeichnet und das ärgerlich ist dass
ich finde ich das doch gut dass sie das
gesagt haben selbst die kritiker glauben
dass also diese sehr erfolgreiche buch
von mir ich glaube dass nichts so sehr
und harald welzer glaubt das auch nicht
aber jubel harari der diese sehr
erfolgreiche buch geschrieben hat mit
dem homo deos das gezeichnet hat der
glaubt dass alles der gerade gleicht
also quasi diesen professor abronsius im
tanz der vampire der das übel dass er so
sehr bekämpft mit sich hinaus in die
welt trägt in dem er glaubt das ist
tatsächlich evolutionär vorherbestimmt
da ist überhaupt nichts revolutionär
feuer bestimmt die leute sagen was
technisch möglich ist wird auch gemacht
die geschichtsvergessen ist das was
waren denn die großen visionen meiner
kindheit riesige städte unter wasser
kolonien auf mars und mond alles nicht
gekommen am ende entscheidet sich
darüber ob das wirtschaftliche modelle
und die frage wer daran partizipiert und
wer daran verdient es ist nichts vorher
besteht
es ist nichts vorher bestimmt da bin ich
eigentlich auf der anderen seite gibt es
die möglichkeiten und wir wissen ebenso
außer technologiegeschichte dass die
möglichkeiten die es gibt dass die in
der regel auch realisiert werden
entscheiden ist ja nicht ob es
realisiert jetzt sondern wie es
realisiert wird und ob wir als
gesellschaft und allerdings hat schon
wieder ein via und da bin ich halt im
politische philosophin ob wir als
gesellschaft mechanismen finden diese
entwicklung ein stück weit zu gestalten
und einhalt zu gebieten ja aber die die
perspektive dass eine bestimmte form von
technologie sich durchgesetzt habe weil
es sie gegeben hat die ist ja um zu
treffen als historisch es gibt viele
technologische entwicklungen die
abgebrochen wurden weil sie nicht
gewollt wurden
eisenbahner amerika durch eine massive
politik der automobilwirtschaft
wir hätten zum beispiel wenn man an den
ökologie bereich denkt hängt es von den
usa bleiben vom präsidenten abstimmen
jimmy carter seine politik weiter
durchgesetzt hätte dann hätten wir heute
möglicherweise nicht die gravierenden
klimawandels probleme hast bei damals
das setzen auf erneuerbare energien und
wir sprechen
30 jahre zurück politikfähig gewesen ist
ja das ist dann jahrzehnte lang nicht
mehr wahr
deshalb ist dann fossile technologie
weiter favorisiert werden und wird es
auch heute noch digitalisierung ist der
dynamisierung von fossiler technologie
und fonds ihren konsum
ich glaube das wollen ist einfach dann
quasi gegeben wenn wir alle diese dinger
benutzen
und selbst wenn sie eine ausnahme sind
technologie hat sich durchgesetzt in die
gesellschaft ist genutzter wenn sie
welches quasi angenommen hat und dann
hat sich durchgesetzt und das rad glaube
ich kann mir nicht zurückdrehen
aber jetzt machen sie ja herr welt sah
die freiheit ganz stark wir können
anders entscheiden es gibt nicht eben
diese fast schon evolutionäre
entwicklung hin zu einem
schreckensszenario was sie zum beispiel
nicht wollen aber ihr buch eines ihrer
letzten bücher heißt die smarte diktatur
und sie stellen es ja schon so das wäre
diese digitalisierung eine art diktatur
also wie viel freiheit bleibt eine der
in einer diktatur oder wo ist jetzt
diese lücke für die freiheit bei ihnen
die bedrohung von demokratie und der
angriff auf die freiheit resultiert aus
ganz vielen aspekten aber nicht ich
nenne mal 2 das eine ist das haben wir
eben auch schon mit angesprochen ist es
wir natürlich ohne ende daten über uns
preis geben jetzt sage ich auch wir bei
gelegentlich bewege selbst ich mich im
internet und so weiter und man weiß
nicht einmal an wen das ist interessant
von selbst verhältnis her
wir wachsen ja auch mit dem bewusstsein
es gibt niemanden der mehr weiß über
mich als ich selber ja das gehört ja
auch zum erwachsenwerden dazu
das stimmt aber nicht mehr das ein
sachverhalt er ist unzutreffend
irgendwer
wir wissen nicht einmal wer weiß mehr
über uns als wir selber metadaten und so
weiter und so weiter das punkt 1.2 ist
zur demokratie gehört die trennung von
privat und öffentlich mit modernen
demokratien ist das überhaupt erst
entstanden wir haben hier eine
öffentliche situation und keine private
und wenn privat halt nicht mehr
existiert und alles durchdrungen ist und
verändern sich die grund verhältnisse
des demokratischen und ich glaube das
sehen wir in der in den politischen
entwicklungen ziehen sich aus
es ist so unsere verfassung von der ich
je in der schweiz jetzt nicht
grundsätzlich anders ist als in
deutschland und den meisten
westeuropäischen staaten die basiert auf
der vorstellung der aufklärung und die
vorstellung der aufklärung ist dass der
mensch frei und mündig ist und dass er
selbst über sich und sein leben
entscheiden soll und dass er seinen
eigenen weg finden soll mit hilfe seiner
urteilskraft was ihm gut tut und was ihm
schlechte und das was harald welzer
beschrieben hat ist eine kybernetische
diktatur das heißt es ist eine welt in
der man nicht mehr pausenlos beobachtet
wird sondern in der man gleichzeitig
weil das verhalten algorithmus er war
ist auch gesteuert werden kann und dann
mit dem entsprechenden system ja also
mit einem belohnungssystem dazu gebracht
wird bestimmte dinge zu tun oder
bestimmte anregungen nichts zu tun und
das ist das gegenteil von urteilskraft
das wäre das ende der epoche der
aufklärung und wir würden dann in eine
andere epoche eingehen das muss erst mal
in dieser dimension wirklich klar
gestellt werden
nun ist es ja so dass wir viele
schutzzäune haben das ist in der schweiz
in deutschland so steht der europäischen
charta das ist das recht auf
informationelle selbstbestimmung kurz
gesagt alles das ist bei uns eigentlich
verboten die ganze digitale ökonomie
basiert auf informationelle
fremdbestimmung und nicht auf
informationelle selbstbestimmung und da
müssen wir ran gehen die europäische
datenschutz grund verordnung war jetzt
ein sperriger versuch mal so lauten
sound zu bauen
aber im grunde genommen müssen wir viel
tiefer in das ganze ein gehen und sagen
das ist grundrechtswidrig und wer diese
grund rechtswidrigkeit ich erkennt der
steht nicht mehr auf dem boden unserer
demokratischen freiheitlichen verfassung
wenn ich ihnen zuhöre dann jetzt glaube
ich doch jetzt am tisch relativ klar die
demokratie ist ein stück weit durch die
digitalisierung bedroht sie sehen da
große schwierigkeit
auf uns zukommen ich möchte gerne mit
jemandem sprechen der das anders sieht
und zwar haben die ihr daniel graf hier
sitzen
daniel graf ist eine person der sich als
netz demokrat bezeichnet von ihm stammt
die agenda für eine digitale demokratie
der zusammen mit max stern herausgegeben
hat diesen frühling was ist netz
demokrat netz demokrat bezahle ich mich
aus ein versuch etwas entgegen der
diskussion ist jetzt läuft zu stellen
weil ich bin überzeugt ich glaube auch
dass digitalisierung auch die sozialen
medien eine produktive kraft haben die
unsere demokratie weiterentwickeln
lassen
und ich glaube auch dass sie ein
versprechen halten dass demokratie in
zukunft eben näher bei den bürgern und
bürgerinnen sein werden dass die bürger
auch mehr möglichkeiten haben den
politischen prozess zu gestalten
ein beispiel was von ihnen stammt habe
eine plattform ihr heißt the collector
sammeln sie stimmen für referenten zum
beispiel und ein beispiel ist das
sogenannte twitter referendum gegen die
sogenannten sozialdetektive und die idee
da war gemeinsam mit sybille berg das
stimmen gesammelt wurde innerhalb von 62
tagen glaube ich hatten sie über 75.000
stimmen um dieses referendum ergreifen
zu können
er ist ehrlich gesagt twitter referendum
das klingt für einen politisch
gebildeten menschen doch ein bisschen
schräg weil man denkt wie kann sich
jemand wirklich politisch eine meinung
bilden mal kurz da eben via twitter also
was passiert ist es dass sibylle berg
eine frage gestellt hat wie macht man
ein referendum es ginge um diese vorlage
und über die willkürliche überwachung
von versicherten wo wir am 25 november
darüber abstimmen werden
und sie hat in die runde gefragt das
haben haben sich leute gewarnt und
gesagt wir wissen wie es geht wir helfen
mit und aus diesen kleinen gruppe sind
innerhalb von wenigen wochen sind ist
eine gruppe von 10.000 bürgern und
bürger entscheiden die gesagt haben wir
machen ein referendum
alle haben das belächelt gesagt ja
wissen schnell gemacht wer schonmal
unterschriften gesammelt auf der straße
weiß das geht nicht so schnell es ist
extrem aufwändig viele scheitern auch
parteien und es hat aber so viel dynamik
gegeben weil es eben zehntausend
menschen waren die gesagt haben wir
wollen das jetzt zur abstimmung bringen
dass es geklappt hat eben in einem
rekordtempo
und das war nur möglich weil die leute
sich vernetzt haben nicht nur über
social media frauen auch über e-mail
aber grundsätzlich sehe ich schon auch
die möglichkeit dass auch bürgerinnen
und bürger auch oder auch parteien und
konzeptionen diese mittel auch einsetzen
können um wirklich und das war das thema
auch am tisch und wirklich auch die
rahmenbedingungen zu ändern und für die
zukunft und dort sehe ich hatte so ein
bisschen die meta-ebene dass wir jetzt
die chance haben unsere demokratie zu
verändern und genau diese probleme
stichwort auch datenschutz die die frage
der technologischen diktatur abzuwenden
und da und da müssen wir auch unser
demokratisches system fit machen
und das machen wir eben auch die mir
diese technologien überprüfen was zu
leisten vermögen also mehr demokratie
dank digitalisierung ihrer meinung nach
genau das nämlich so mit an den tisch
mehr demokratie dank digitalisierung
aber muss er zunächst mal sagen es geht
nicht darum eine technik zu begrüßen um
dort eine technik zu verteufeln
es geht nicht darum zu sagen eine
technik schafft demokratie oder eine
technik schafft demokratie ab nun ist
die frage was man für gebrauch davon
macht ich hatte am anfang das was jetzt
passiert mit der ersten industriellen
revolution vernichten was soll ich denn
sagen die dampfmaschine und der beginn
der technologie die damals begann der
industrieproduktion
was hat dass die welt besser gemacht
oder die welt schlechter gemacht wenn
sie die leute gefragt hätten 1830 oder
1850 dann waren 80 prozent der
bevölkerung von den segnungen der ersten
industriellen revolution komplett
ausgeschlossen
die hatten den 16 stunden tag da wurden
die kinder in den bergwerken verheizt
und und und im nachhinein kann man sagen
das ganze war ein segen der uns diesen
wahnsinnigen wohlstand beschert hat die
wir heute leben
andererseits kann man sagen wenn wir 50
jahre so weiter macht die erde kaputt
sodass hat es zeigt nur wie groß die
schwierigkeit ist eine technik überhaupt
zu bewerten sondern es ist natürlich
eine frage erstens der perspektive der
gesellschaftlichen umstände der
gegenreaktion und die erste industrielle
revolution hat gegen den radikalen
kapitalismus ein gegengift gebraucht das
war die arbeiter bewegung die
gewerkschaften der sozialismus damit es
überhaupt zum segen von vielen wurde und
zumindest es in den reichen
industrieländern und das ist bei der
digitalisierung genauso wie wir das
schaffen lassen und nur den
großinvestoren im silicon valley
überlassen es sind ja nicht die saka
works oder prinz das sind riesige polen
in der das geld der welt rhein fließt
diese enorme wertsteigerung in diese
unternehmen haben eine einzig und allein
damit zusammen wie viel kapital aus
saudi arabien aus norwegen aus malaysia
von überall in der welt da hingeht und
diese sache die müssen investiert werden
wie der kapitalismus anfang des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts domestiziert
werden musste da bin ich ganz bei ihnen
aber ich möchte trotzdem noch schnell
auf das eingehen was der kollege gesagt
ich meine in der schweiz kennen wir die
direkte demokratie wir können
unterschriften sammeln wir können damit
referenten machen
der punkt ist dass ich finde diese
dieses vorgehen auch gut und ich finde
dass wichtigen das wird referenten und
abstimmungen erleichtern
auf der anderen seite haben wir die
ewige alte diskussion über die erhöhung
der unterschriftenzahl die mit solchen
mechanismen und plötzlich wirklich sehr
sehr dringend wird aber viel entscheiden
dabei das momentum das richtig zu
verstehen sie finden es braucht zu
wenige unterschriften zum beispiel ein
referendum zusammen genau ganz genau und
unter diesen umständen erst recht also
man könnte warum denn sie sind doch auch
für demokratie warum sollen sich da
nicht 75.000 leute zusammen tun und
sagen so nicht meine herren oder damen
weil wir eine demokratie geschaffen
haben die nicht einfach allein nur von
einer mehrheit und von der zahl lebt
sondern weil wir eine demokratie
geschaffen haben die durchaus in
institutionen eingebettet ist aber
aktiver auch an doch auch eben von unten
her
ja genau auswählen und ein stück weit
kann man doch auch sagen und das glaube
ich wäre der punkt von ihnen berichtigen
sie mich wenn es nicht stimmt dem volk
wirklich die macht zurück zu geben auch
es aber in der demokratie geht es darum
dass genau personenkreise die nicht im
parlament vertreten sind das die die
möglichkeit haben ein
parlamentsentscheid zu kippen
wie oft begreifen demokratie heute immer
als ein spielfeld wo organisationen
parteien initiativen und referenden
lassen nein das ist nicht die idee es
ist wirklich idee das gucken die nicht
vertreten sind einfach ein veto einlegen
können und so ein referendar von
bürgerinnen und bürgern gekommen ist das
gibt es eine geschichte einfach paar mal
aber sehr selten weil die schwelle und
dass es geht auch um kosten das ist
nicht mal unterschriften sammeln sondern
hat das kostet auch relativ viel
es ist einfach nicht so einfach möglich
um dort sehen wir einfach dass die die
neuen kanäle zumindest ermöglichen dass
bürgerinnen und bürger
den ball in die hand nehmen können und
auch erfolgreich waren referenten
durchführen was ich wichtig finde ist
das egal wie sie es machen dass man die
institutionen und mechanismen der
entscheidfindung beibehält dass es immer
noch checks and balances gibt das ist
immer noch institutionen gibt die
überprüfen die abwägen die pro und
contra machen können und es verschiedene
entscheid läuft es gibt sie wiegt ex es
gibt neue junge leute die das quasi
alles weg haben wollen und sagen wir
machen wonach smartphone gemacht nur auf
twitter wir haben einfach eine eine
mehrheit per iphone und damit reagieren
wir und da wäre ich entschieden dagegen
das ist nicht der ansatz aber ich glaube
das muss man sehr genau
auseinanderhalten wenn man darüber
spricht aber ist das nicht eine
eigenartige situation auf der einen
seite haben wir angst unsere freiheit zu
verlieren uns überhaupt noch einbringen
zu können überhaupt noch gestalten zu
können und auf der anderen seite haben
wir jetzt plötzlich angst was
irgendwelche leute mit irgendwas machen
könnten uns dann von unter die haut
macht übernehmen ist das nicht ein
widerspruch
das ist gar kein widerspruch also ich
glaube erst mal muss man sagen bei
solchen ansätzen wie herr graf sie
vertritt muss man ganz deutlich sagen
das funktioniert in einer
funktionierenden demokratie
ja ich möchte dieses instrument nicht
eingesetzt werden eingesetzt sehen in
diktaturen diktatoren und autoritäre
herrscher sind absolute fans von
volksabstimmungen warum weil jede
aktuelle stimmung instrumentalisiert bar
ist und die parlamentarische demokratie
hat mit guten gründen verzögerungen
eingebaut und sie ist dementsprechend
keine stimmungs gesellschaft sondern
eine die mechanismen hat das rationale
entscheidung getroffen werden können der
andere punkt ist der dass sich in den
letzten jahrzehnten zivilgesellschaft
immer weiter entpolitisiert und aus der
politischen debatte rausgezogen hat wir
haben niedergang von protestkultur
gehabt an ganz vielen stellen
wir haben sozusagen kultiviertes das
interesse an den öffentlichen
angelegenheit
gehabt und die demokratie würde schon
auch noch funktionieren nicht digital
wenn sie so laufen würde wie sie gedacht
gewesen ist dass der die die sich als
demokraten fühlen an bestimmten stellen
tatsächlich auch in den prozess
einbringen das dauert dann ein bisschen
länger als über klicks oder sowas ja und
der andere punkt mit dieser twitter
nummer auch da muss man sich ja
überlegen wer von den real existierenden
politikern benutzt das denn mit
absoluter mit absoluten enthusiasmus und
das sind ja nun gerade nicht die
gestalten denen wir jetzt angemalt das
höchstmaß an aufgeklärtheit rationalität
und gut willigkeit unterstellen
deutschland wäre das war der
piratenpartei gesehen die das gefühl hat
er das netz wäre ihres und wenn sie an
direkte demokratie dachte dann dachten
ihre zirkel also hoch interessierte
junge leute wahnsinnig engagiert und sie
haben eigentlich nie wirklich darüber
nachgedacht dass es gute gründe gab die
demokratie sei den alten griechen immer
langsamer zu machen
bei den alten griechen konnte man an
einem tag durch das schöffengericht
verurteilt werden da wurde der prozess
an einem tag gemacht da gab es keine
berufungskammer gar nix und wenn man
dann später die geschichte der
demokratie ansieht einführung der
gewaltenteilung erst in england dann in
frankreich in deutschland usw alles ist
ging um entschleunigung
es ging um entschleunigung um die
politik aus dem affekt zu befreien und
jede form extremer direkter demokratie
bringt die politik in den effekt zurück
und wie will man langfristige
entscheidungen über solche komplizierten
probleme wie diplomatische beziehungen
die man mit ländern unterhält usw
effekten ausliefern das würde sich von
tag zu tag würde sich das meinungsbild
verändern und am ende würde man sich der
manipulation durch medien aussetzen der
etablierten medien aber auch der medien
die im grunde am stillschweigend hinter
den sozialen netzwerken sind und
jederzeit in der lage dem stimmung
hervor zu rufen und zu beeinflussen
wir gehen wir denn eigentlich mit dieser
zeit um den dass ich ja eigentlich die
frage die uns interessiert was macht die
digitalisierung mit uns menschen und mit
unserer gesellschaft und jetzt haben wir
doch einfach unterschiedliche
darstellungen
herr graf würde das anders beschreiben
wie sie das beschreiben
und wir sprechen über die zukunft es ist
nicht so klar wie sich das alles weiter
integriert sie haben gesagt es geht
nicht darum
nur darüber zu sprechen ist eine
technologie schlecht oder gut sondern
immer der gebrauch macht sich zu einer
guten oder schlechten sache das ist ja
eigentlich klar aber wie entscheiden wir
denn welcher gebrauch ein guter brauch
ist das ist glaube ich gar nicht so
schwer die einigkeit ist groß also ja
jahre alt ist groß wer jetzt nicht von
den von den leuten die ihr geld bei
facebook oder bei google verdienen aber
wenn ich jetzt darüber rede ist und
sagen was jemand der ceo an den verein
ist großen deutschen konzerns ist was
der privat darüber denkt dass seine
kinder zu viel handy benutzen und das
hier nicht mehr richtig kreativ sind und
das ja gar den der zukunft immer mehr
kreative menschen benötigt werden durch
den wandel in der arbeitswelt aber immer
mehr rezeptiven menschen hervorgebracht
werden
das sagen leute die konservative
parteien wählen das sagen leute die
linke parteien wählen das sagen leute
die busfahrer sind und das sagen leute
die große unternehmen leiten in dem
punkt besteht gar kein großer dissenz
glauben sie sind auch der lizenz besteht
eher darin wie man das dann eben auch
nicht umsetzt oder was ist ja eigentlich
frage ich sehe das schon auch man weiß
schon dass man sich selber grenzen
setzen müssen der punkt ist ja und dann
sind wir wieder beim wir wer setzt sind
diese grenzen reichen denn einfach
appelle und sagen gelegt ein smartphone
weg machen gehe ich mein bekenntnis der
geschichten die jugendliche die ihren
smartphone auf den tisch legen bevor sie
miteinander ersten familien die sich ein
die talks wochenende quasi verordnet es
gibt ja diese versuche und ich glaube
die sind auch wichtig die frage ist nur
reichen diese appelle oder braucht es
mehr und wenn es mehr braucht dann
brauchen wir verordnung dann brauchen
wir gesetze dann brauchen wir verbote
und dann ist die schwelle zudem zu der
diktatur sage ich jetzt zu quasi macht
die menschen anders als das sie sind
dann ist eben bald schon angekratzt und
deshalb glaube ich müssen wir letztlich
oder sagen wir so ich bin so
optimistisch und vertraut auf so das dmi
wir gelernt haben mit anderen
technologien umzugehen lernen wir auch
mit diesen technologien umzugehen
in kleinen in großen müssen wir sehr
wohl über wirtschaftspolitik über
steuerpolitik über sozialpolitik ze
sprechen das schon aber im kleinen
glaube ich mir was ist jetzt das
erinnern was ist das große das kleine
ist wie verhalte ich mich gegenüber
diesen medien wie viel wie viel mal pro
tag füttere ich diese wie viel man total
konsultiere ich diese was bilden
damit alles ab wie sehr lasse ich mich
von denen leiten was ich denke was ich
tue was ich sehe worüber ich mich
informieren oder sage ich nein ich
versuche doch trotzdem noch selber zu
entscheiden was ich mir anschaue und was
ist was ich wegstecke was ich nicht
quasi all das spricht doch die empirie
total dagegen jeder tritt vor die tür
das beobachten von menschen im
öffentlichen raum in der tram in welcher
situation ich ja doch alle sozusagen lag
ich in dieser filter welt unterwegs und
das wird durch eine form von
selbstbeschränkung nicht funktionieren
zumal es einfach auch so ist dass das
dass die benutzung dieser geräte selber
eine sucht struktur etabliert und auch
etablieren soll
weil man kann damit super gut geld
verdienen und supergut daten erheben
denn diese sucht struktur funktioniert
nicht umsonst werden jede menge
neurowissenschaftler im silicon valley
beschäftigt es jetzt keine
verschwörungstheorie sondern sich
schlicht und ergreifend so weil man weiß
wie kann man am besten belohnungssystem
im gehirn aktivieren
durch welche form von von mitteilung und
likes und so weiter und so weiter und es
erschreckende ist doch das funktioniert
bombe es funktioniert total bombe es
funktioniert so super dass ich mir
vorkomme wieder einzige zombie auf der
welt weil ja das ist ja das ist die weil
die sozialen verhaltensweisen die formen
der kommunikation die selbst
verhältnisse begegnen miteinander um hat
sich in den vergangenen zehn jahren wir
sprechen über zehn jahre
wenn wir über das smartphone sprechen in
einer so radikalen art und weise
verändert wie ich das historisch nicht
also habe ich kein vergleichs beispiel
ja und das ist ohne dass man das
vielleicht jetzt gleich verteufelt oder
sowas immerhin ein bemerkenswerter
befund
man könnte jetzt politisch sagen das
finden wir super und dann kann man gegen
leute wie mich argumentieren die das
nicht super findet dann hätte man eine
politische situation
wir haben aber eine totale schräglage in
der debatte deshalb habe ich vorhin
abgesagt so viele kritiker gibt es doch
gar nicht es gibt auch viel mehr
befürworter nämlich alle die die das
benutzern die diskussion und ein
vereinfachtes in dienst
nur in der schweiz eine umfrage machen
worauf seid ihr eher bereit zu
verzichten auf euer wahlrecht oder auf
euer smartphone warum widerspricht sich
das schwierige frage
nur als beispiel nur satt zu machen wie
die prioritäten sonst machen wir das war
die frage ist mart phone oder wahlrecht
für mich ist ja klar wahlrecht natürlich
will ich jetzt ja auch nicht blamieren
glaube ich mit der falschen antwort aber
ein wichtiger punkt sein wir schauen was
wir haben eher aus wahlrecht verzichten
das war die frage
vielleicht kann sie aber noch zwei drei
sätze mehr sagen warum denn
oder ist es sowieso die falsche frage
ist es eine lächerliche fragen die blöde
frage was auch immer unheimlich habe die
demokratie ist ein entscheidendes
stichwort und damit eben auch das
wahlrecht ich finde das extrem wichtig
und ich glaube hier ist ein punkt der
mir auch am herzen liegt ihr dürfen auch
unseren mitmenschen ein bisschen mehr
vertrauen entgegenbringen ich habe in
dieser ganzen diskussion die
digitalisierung immer das gefühl ja die
anderen sind die deppen also irgendwie
die elite findet das vorgestellt das
volk findet irgendwie delhi zerlegt und
gegen die linken die rechten schwierig
und die rechten finden die linken und
zwei anstatt zu sagen hey sind ja einer
demokratie und das baut darauf auf dass
wir eigentlich mündige bürgerinnen und
bürger sind und ich glaube ihnen die
leute in diesem rahmen auch den menschen
da draußen die nicht steirische
unterschiedlichen sprachen zu dass
irgendwo mit der situation der welt
umgehen können und wir jetzt nicht dazu
radikalen maßnahmen greifen müssen und
immer die anderen aus quasi zombies und
ob fordert regionalisieren was in die
frei sind mündig sind nicht in einer
diktatur wie es bei ihnen sind sie in
einer diktatur und was möchten sie
lieber abgeben wahlrecht oder handy
ich würde lieber mein handy abgeben ganz
klar ich würde mir wünsche ich könnte es
mehr abgeben und ich würde gerne wissen
was ich machen kann ja oder wie ich
meine wie ich davon mehr weg darf ich
sie noch fragen
ich würde auch mein smartphone
verzichten klar aber irgendwie geht es
mir ähnlich wie den beiden
ich glaube müssen positive denken ich
glaube müssen den jugendlichen auch
zulassen dass sie ihren weg gehen und
dass die digitalisierung einteilen
unsere welt heute ist und wie viel
positive darüber denken sollten
wer hat recht sagte die industrielle
revolution brachte und so viel negatives
aber auch sehr viel positives
wir müssen schritt für schritt damit
ländern umzugehen und regeln zu stellen
vielleicht gehen wir zurück mal kurz
noch einmal zu diesem beispiel mit der
industriellen revolution weil das ja
wirklich etwas ist was sie in ihrem buch
auch ausführlich besprechen ab recht was
sie sagen es gab drei industrielle
revolution die wir recht gut eigentlich
überlebt haben jetzt stecken wir in der
vierten und jetzt jetzt brandgefährlich
unter anderem auch weil es noch um einen
weiteren punkt geht nämlich um die frage
wer eigentlich genau das sagen hat und
das hängt auch damit zusammen wer zum
beispiel noch arbeit hat das ist ja auch
noch mal so eine frage geht uns oder
geht vielen wirklich was den helfen der
menschen die arbeit aus und was würde
die machtverhältnisse noch einmal
drastisch verschieben
also die spannende frage ist ja was mit
der arbeit versteht also werden wir
sagen arbeit ist jede form von tätigkeit
auch wenn ich meinen garten umgraben
dann geht uns die arbeit nicht aus wenn
ich aber sage
sozialversicherungspflichtige lohn und
erwerbsarbeit
hier wurde ja erst in der ersten
industriellen revolution überhaupt
eingeführt gibt es ja noch nicht lange
vor 300 400 jahren hat kein schweizer
für geld gearbeitet sodass hat sich
irgendwann durch die erste industrielle
revolution durch die neue struktur die
entstanden ist ist auch diese form von
beschäftigungsstruktur entstanden so und
das war der beginn des ersten maschinen
zeitalters und jetzt kommen wir ins
zweite maschinen zeitalter und da werden
die ganzen intelligenz berufe ersetzt
nicht alle aber eine nicht
unbeträchtliche form davon also sehr
viele verwaltungsjobs banken
versicherungs jobs justiziare die bei
firmen arbeiten könnte das stück für
stück durch gehen und dann würden auch
für die schweiz eine ganze menge viele
viele hunderttausend menschen
zusammenkommen jetzt spielt der
demografische faktor in den meisten
westeuropäischen ländern nicht in
frankreich aber in deutschland der
schweiz das ganz günstig war ja nicht
ganz so viel kinder nachkommen
aber im prinzip müssen wir uns darauf
einrichten dass die arbeitslosigkeit
stark steigt so da gibt es ein paar ganz
schlaue ökonomen die ersten tagen aber
herr brecht sie wissen doch gar nicht
wie viel millionen neue geschäft
jungs verhältnis alle durch die
digitalisierung entstehen sie berufen
sich danach die gebildeten darunter
denen auf david ricardo berühmte
englische ökonomen der 1817 die
kompensations theorie aufgestellt hat
der gesagt hat immer wenn der technische
fortschritt irgendwo arbeit kills
schaffte auf der anderen seite mehr neue
das ist so dass man tragen das ist das
glaubensbekenntnis der ökonomen dass das
jetzt passieren soll und das ist
ausgesprochen unwahrscheinlich weil ich
glaube auch dass ganz viele neue arbeit
entsteht aber doch nicht für menschen
es entsteht ganz viele neue arbeit für
maschinen zweitens ein ganz wichtiger
punkt noch die kompensations theorie bei
abhängig von wachsenden märkten das hat
nur deswegen funktioniert weil
gleichzeitig die welt sich immer weiter
globalisiert hat und immer gewaltigere
absatzmärkte für die produkte entstanden
sind
und damals konkurrierten in der ersten
industriellen revolution england und
holland und ein bisschen deutschland und
später frankreich miteinander heute
konkurrieren die volkswirtschaften von
zwei milliarden menschen miteinander und
das wachstumspotenzial durch die
globalisierung ist begrenzt da kann man
mir nicht mit david ricardos
kompensations theorie co das heißt die
arbeit geht viele menschen aus also die
regelmäßige klassische erwerbsarbeit
dass ich acht und 30 oder 40 stunden am
tag irgendwo hinkriege und erwähnte
lohntüte dafür kriege und die
sozialversicherung ein hätten das wird
relativ viel mit nicht allen aber es
würde reichen wenn ein drittel aller
schweizer in den nächsten 25 jahren
davon betroffen ist und die schweiz
werden anderes land ziehen diese zahlen
ja umstritten da die frau gentinetta
sehen das leicht anders
ja ich meine wir wissen ja alle nicht
was kommt und ich kenne auch ein paar
kluge ökonomen die sagen sie wissen
nicht was kommt
aber es gibt doch auch interessante
befunde ich gebe zu diesen gleichen die
vergangenheit gericht aber jetzt noch
mal die letzten 20 jahre anschaut wo man
nicht in die für industrielle revolution
geht sondern die letzten 20 jahre hat
auch in der schweiz beschäftigung fast
20 prozent zugenommen und zwar da möchte
ich einfach vielleicht leicht
korrigieren sind nicht die intelligenz
jobs die weggehen sind die routinejob
sie weggehen das ist etwas was man jetzt
eindeutig beachten kann die
intelligenten jobs bleiben die routine
jobs fallen weg und die einfachen jobs
bleiben wiederum das heißt es braucht
nach wie vor menschen die diese
produktionsstätten die automatisiert
sind betreuen die sie aufsetzen die sie
kontrollieren dies überwachen
hier auch mal einspringen können wenn
etwas nicht geht dazu braucht es
spontanität dazu braucht es analyse dazu
braucht es eine spontane kombination
dazu braucht es die fähigkeit einen
entscheid zu fällen den nicht
vorprogrammiert ist das ist ja genau der
punkt diese jobs sind nach wie vor
gesucht und die sind da und was es auch
braucht auf der anderen seite sind die
ganz einfachen dinge wir wollen uns
vielleicht nicht unbedingt in ein selbst
liegen das flugzeug setzen selbst wenn
das möglich ist dass da bin ich ganz bei
ihnen
das heißt es geht auch um die akzeptanz
von solchen berufen pflegeberufen wo es
direkt um den kontakt zwischen menschen
gibt die nehmen zu
sie nehmen nach wie vor zu und das ist
einfach ein befund den man aus solchen
einmal zu versehen befunden widerspreche
ich nicht ich halte nur die empirische
basis für klein also die anzahl der
empathie berufe die es in zukunft geben
wird die wird groß sein
ohne jeden zweifel und auch in der
intelligenten fabrik braucht mal oben
paar supervisor und selbst wenn es
intelligente semantische suchmaschinen
gibt je die hälfte aller juristen
ersetzen braucht man die andere hälfte
noch aber nur mal um ribéry an die
zahlen nachzudenken wenn tatsächlich
selbst fahrenden fahrzeuge kommen also
alle busse ja alle alle straßenbahnen
alle taxiverkehr und was weiß ich was
dahin steht doch nicht auf der anderen
seite genauso viel neue also dass im
augenblick ist das ein zweck optimismus
den wir machen wir lügen uns in die
eigene tasche weil wir uns nicht damit
auseinander setzen wollen dass wir eine
enorme gesellschaftliche veränderung
kriegen wenn wir keine klassische lohn
und erwerbsarbeit für die meisten mehr
sind und das ist der grund warum wir
brauchen endlich jene ökonomen die sagen
ach ja ist doch früher auch immer gut
gegangen und passiert ja nicht so weiter
im augenblick so viel oberwasser
wir können die empirische basis schon
noch etwas ausweiten auf die anderen
führenden industriellen revolutionen in
denen es am schluss immer mehr arbeit
gab als vorher stimmt obwohl man das
gegenteil das ist das ist das ist
sozusagen die klassische lüge früher
haben die leute in der ersten
industriellen revolution 80 stunden am
tag gearbeitet heute arbeiten sie noch
die hälfte
früher haben 80 prozent aller frauen
gearbeitet nämlich entweder in der
landwirtschaft oder später in den
fabriken
früher haben alle kinder gearbeitet ab
dem siebten oder achten lebensjahr
und wenn sie mal gucken mit welchem
alter man heute in den beruf einsteigt
25 27 und so weiter und dann gucken dann
geht die these nicht genau und sie sagen
aber ganz egal wie es die empirische
lage wirklich ist mir wissen sie auch
nicht herauskommt wird aber sie sagen
ist ja eine gute
nichts also wir wollen ja keine kinder
aber wir wollen ja keine frauen die zu
hause in der fabrik und alles und die
fragen dafür sind sozusagen befreien
abschied von der leistungsgesellschaft
gute nachricht wenn wir entsprechende
maßnahmen nicht absicht davon lassen
wenn nicht ab das ist es nicht zu ende
dass menschen leistung bringen nicht
dass leute bestätigung brauche nicht
dass leute das gefühl haben wollen am
tag was geleistet zwar nicht diese form
von leistungsgesellschaft
aber es ist doch großartig wenn diese
haben das ja gesagt routine jobs
wenn die jetzt wegfallen also das sind
jobs die würde ich nicht gerne machen ja
und wenn die meisten von diesen jobs am
finanzamt arbeiten und so weiter es gibt
leute meinen dass auch gerne aber viele
leute wollen das eigentlich machen und
man wird diesen berufen nicht in 20 30
jahren hinterher trauern
genauso wenig wie man den bergbau oder
den stahlkocher und heute hinterher
trauert so und dann kommen wir in eine
gesellschaft wo die leute viel mehr
überlegungen haben sich zu sagen was
will ich denn eigentlich arbeiten das
denn eigentlich sinnvoll was macht man
eigentlich glücklich wie kann ich denn
so arbeiten dass ich meine kinder dabei
sehe und so weiter und so weiter
das ganze ist eine fortschritts
entwicklung und um den fortschritt zu
haben müssen wir aus der klassischen
struktur aus genau und weil ich vorhin
dieses votum hc es ist ja alles zu
negativ müssen auch mal vertrauen haben
es war das positive sehen habe ich
dieses thema eingebracht hatte ich ganz
genau wusste ja brechen ihnen steckt ja
auch ein positiver blick auf die
digitalisierung da sind ja richtig gut
news ich finde das großartig wenn ich
überlege wie die wie die bauern in der
schweiz im 18 jahrhundert auf den
feldern gearbeitet hatten
ich war die schweiz war das armenhaus
europas ja in den bergen wo es heute
schönes da waren hier sozusagen um
fruchtbarsten wiesen
da konnte man kein getreide anbauen und
so weiter und wenn man dann guckt wenn
man sich die ganze entwicklung
angekommen heute geht es den schweizern
großartig und sie arbeiten viel weniger
als sie gearbeitet haben haben sie sich
tod gearbeitet da waren 47 tod hatten
keine zähne mehr im mund waren tot ist
eine tolle entwicklung und winter das
stück für stück weiter durchgehe
fabrikarbeit wie das aussah im 19
jahrhundert in england in deutschland
usw
dann ist das ganze eine unglaublich
positive entwicklung und wir müssen nun
die nächsten sprung in der positiven
entwicklung machen und der besteht eben
darin dass wir jetzt anfangen wie
langweilige routine jobs zu schreddern
das ist doch großartig großartig
digitalisierung ist doch großartig sagt
ich habe ja nie was gegenteil
wirklichen aber wir sind auch hier genau
an der an der wirklich interessanten
stelle nämlich ob man gewissermaßen
entwicklungen für gegeben hält und dann
irgendwie dem versucht hinterher zu
kommen oder ob man sagt okay jetzt lasst
uns doch mal ein wort hier vorgang
machen was ist denn möglicherweise bei
einer frage in welcher gesellschaft
wollen wir leben welche arbeitswelt
wollen wir haben was kann uns dabei
digitalisierung helfen oder andere
technologische entwicklungen auch diese
frage stellen wer nicht sein
das hat man ja zu anfang das ist alles
da und das geht auch nicht mehr zurück
und dann hechtet man hinterher und
unterhält sich darüber sind 40 prozent
der jobs oder 45 oder verlernt
jetzt stellten jetzt ihr jetzt stellen
wir sehen die stimme ihn recht
vollkommen zu das ist natürlich das
reich der freiheit in greifbare nähe ist
wenn es keine arbeit mehr gibt ja und
das geht ja sehr weit
es könnte nämlich dann zum beispiel auch
zur folge haben dass die ja wirklich
eben mit der arbeiterbewegung
paradoxerweise in die welt gekommene
hoch bewertung und entfremdete arbeit
mal wieder wegkommt es ist doch nicht
der sinn weshalb wir alle auf die welt
gekommen sind ja 40 jahre lang irgendwie
dasselbe zu tun
ja ich werde jetzt ein sozialdemokrat
hier am tisch sitzen würde würde sagen
aber sehr wohl ist es der sinn und das
wollen wir nie wieder aufgeben
wir wollen dummes zeug machen ein ganzes
leben und das nennen wir dann sinn des
lebens und wertvolle existenz so das ist
nicht alternativ was die alternative ist
wir haben gerne zusätzlich noch ein
problem über das wir gar nicht
gesprochen haben dass in den meisten
ländern dieses typs das ganze komplette
sozialsysteme auf besteuerung von arbeit
basiert was schon vollkommen klar es ist
seit jahrzehnten schon deppert das zu
machen
ja wieso eigentlich das was produktiv
ist besteuern und zum beispiel nicht
produktive sachen die kapitaleinkünfte
finanztransaktionen und dergleichen
dinge nicht zu besteuern
das heißt wir hätten einen moment wo man
sagen kann wir sind jetzt in der
in einem strukturwandel der arbeitswelt
dieser strukturwandel sie zwingend einen
strukturwandel in den ganzen
sozialsystemen nach sich also haben wir
doch eine coole gelegenheit lasst uns
doch roboter besteuern lasst uns
finanztransaktionen besteuern lasst uns
ganz andere quellen von steuern und dann
können wir das spiel völlig neue spielen
und sagen ach müssen gar nicht alle
arbeiten
es müssen gar nicht alle arbeiten
vielleicht gibt es leute haben keine
lust zu arbeiten
naja brauchen sie halt nicht zu arbeiten
ist doch super also wir haben sozusagen
können das spiel mal völlig umdrehen
hätte zu scherzen
dies hätte hätte ich ganz gravierende
konsequenzen auch im bereich
nachhaltigkeit und so weiter und so
weiter wenn man leute nicht sich ständig
entschädigen müssen für den mist den sie
acht stunden am tag machen brauchen sie
auch nicht so viel konsumieren
[Applaus]
alle welt dank ende der euro genau ich
glaube wir müssen vielleicht noch zwei
dinge klären wir haben zuerst darüber
gesprochen wie viele arbeit wegfällt ich
glaube da kann man unterschiedlicher
meinung sein man weiß das sag ich genau
dass die arbeit schöner wird das von
tina arbeiten weg fahren finde ich auch
wunderbar abgesehen davon dass wir uns
in dieser arbeitswelt schon sowieso neu
organisiert haben mein büro besteht aus
meinem laptop und meinem iphone meinem
ipad ich bei mir habe egal wo ich bin
und ich entscheiden ob ich arbeite oder
nicht ich habe keinen arbeitgeber der
wie gesagt du musst morgens ein stempel
arbeitsausstand und bitte macht
zwischendurch zeigt zwei kaffeepausen
weil das gesetz das verordnet das habe
ich nicht in das haben ganz viele nicht
mehr ich glaube wir haben uns längst
oder viele von uns haben uns längst aus
dieser alten struktur verabschiedet die
gibt es nicht mehr
sie wird auch eingefordert von einer
jüngeren generation die ganz andere
ansprüche an die arbeitswelt hat die
viel mehr sinn fragen stellt die ihre
arbeits arbeitgeber weiß gott mit
solchen fragen konfrontiert und die sehr
wohl genau wissen wollen was mache ich
da eigentlich für wen arbeitet
eigentlich das stellt auch unternehmen
vor ganz neue fragen
das einzige wo ich nicht bei ihnen bin
und diese rolle ist immer so undankbar
ich bin natürlich nicht für eine roboter
steuer ich bin nicht für eine
finanztransaktionssteuer
ich bin schon gar nicht für ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen weil ich
glaube dass all diese dinge letztlich
strukturen die wir etabliert haben und
von denen wir wissen dass sie
funktionieren einfach ein für alle mal
einen haufen das hat mir das ganz klar
warum jetzt plötzlich das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen auskommen aber da hatten
wir noch gar nicht gesprochen haben
das ist ja ich mal der fonds im raum hat
sich letztlich in das sozusagen das
momentum dass sie angesprochen haben wir
haben einen moment wo wir über dinge
sprechen konnten
glücklich waren für dich ich habe völlig
dass sie das lob der bestehenden arbeits
von leistungsgesellschaft singen weil es
den menschen in der schweiz wahnsinnig
gut geht und deswegen verstehe ich das
auch dass man denken was change a
winning team ist doch großartig was ich
nur prognostiziere ist ist wird
langfristig erhalten bleiben ob man will
oder nicht man muss sich auf die
veränderungen einstellen wenn man wenn
man bei arbeitsleistungen vom
politischen leben gesprochen dass sie
meinen auch jetzt weil sie sind
sozusagen gegen eine veränderung der
steuern gehen sie sagt die arbeitswelt
verändert sich das politische system
nicht antasten gentinetta nicht so
radikal anpassung ja also wenn man
anfang des neunzehnten jahrhunderts das
ist ein wichtiger vergleich war das
erklärt was ich meine wenn man damals
den kapitalisten in england oder ende
des achtzehnten erzählt hast du musst
deine arbeit verbessere bezahlen an das
schaffst du nie einen richtigen
binnenmarkt für deine tuch produktion
und der kapitalismus wird nicht
funktionieren dann haben damals alle
gesagt die philosophen bleibt bei john
law closed alle ökonomen ein 1 1
dann muss die arbeiter so schlecht wie
irgend möglich bezahlen damit man
wettbewerbsvorteile vor den anderen
ländern hat und das haben alle
ausnahmslos alle ökonomen 50 60 jahren
heruntergebetet und erst als man unter
dem druck der arbeiterbewegung anfing
seine arbeit ordentlich zu bezahlen
wurde das politische system stabil
entstanden entsprechende binnenmärkte
stieg der volkswohl stand und so weiter
und wir sind wieder in einer situation
wo second maschine age totale revolution
arbeitswelt wo wir eine situation kommen
und sagen okay das wird völlig anders
sein als das bisher gewesen erst hier
müssen unsere sozialen sicherungssysteme
anpassen und wir können und da begebe
ich harald welzer völlig recht über die
besteuerung von arbeit die nicht mehr
finanzieren weil selbst wenn es ja sein
könnte dass durch die demographie zum
beispiel in deutschland gar nicht so
viele arbeitslos werden aber trotzdem
mehr und mehr arbeit von robotern
gemacht wird und diese arbeit war von
robotern und computer nicht besteuert
wird
dann würde angesichts der tatsache dass
wir alle vorhaben 90 oder 100 zu werden
und immer weniger einzahlen unser
sozialsystem sowieso kaputt gehen und
die ganze überlegung ist grundeinkommen
ist welche clevere idee gebe es was
könnte man noch besteuern was könnte man
anstelle des umlage systems stellen was
möglicherweise funktioniert das ist der
ausgangspunkt für das grundeinkommen
es gibt ja noch einen anderen aspekt
roboter kaufen ja auch nicht ein solar
soweit wir wissen wir sind ja ziemlich
schlechte kommen wollen doch das
shopping abschalten
doch super nein systemische gedacht
entsteht an ihrem leben glaube ich dass
sich so einfach nicht lösen lässt wenn
die zahl der aktiv am arbeitsmarkt
partizipierenden geringer wird was ist
dann mit unserem hyper konsum system wie
teilt sich das neu auf also nur in
erster linie von von rechts
argumentation uns gibt es auch noch
einen anderen aspekt wo ich ein haken
würde
es ist ja nicht zutreffend dass sich
unsere arbeitswelt so teuer verändert
hätte es gibt auch in dieser
gesellschaft und in der bundesrepublik
und noch mehr in so genannten
schwellenländern und noch mehr in armen
ländern sehr sehr viele menschen die auf
unglaubliche haare und altmodische art
und weise buckeln und rackern und machen
und tun und kein laptop in der hand
haben und das sagt ja auch noch etwas
aus worauf nämlich unsere schöne neue
welt basiert ja zum beispiel sind ja all
diese gerätschaften der stecken ja
rohstoffe drin und diese rohstoffe
regnen ja nicht aus apple fabriken raus
sondern die werden ja irgendwo gewonnen
und zwar mit sehr harter arbeit also ich
finde diesen aspekt muss man auch mal
mit einbeziehen
das ist nämlich wiederum indiz dafür
dass wir über veränderungsprozesse aus
einer sehr engen perspektive diskutieren
die rohstoff thematik wird durch die
digitalisierung verschärft und nicht
entschärft so da kriegen wir probleme
die die ausbeutung situation für große
teile einer für uns nicht sichtbaren
arbeiterschaft wird verschärft und nicht
entschärft ich würde gerne an dieser
stelle nochmals einen schritt machen und
einfach nur fragen wer ist denn dieses
wir wir haben jetzt ganz viel davon
gehört
wir müssen ändern wir brauchen ein
abfedern wenn die arbeit knapp wird wir
müssen irgendwie schauen dass wir die
digitalisierung klug nutzen aus dieser
technologie das gute rausholen wer ist
denn wir weil was ich überhaupt nicht
mehr hören kann ist immer dieses reden
davon
wir brauchen eine debatte dann geht man
so zufrieden nach hause wir brauchen
eine debatte um das ist überhaupt nichts
passiert
wer denn was denn die im raum sind ja
die standard antwort die ich auf diese
frage geben richten ist immer die es
sind die die im raum sind bei
diskussionen laufen immer so die gehen
immer über die gerade nicht da sind die
jugendlichen oder die älteren oder die
ich habe es eben mit den arbeitern in
der dritten welt oder so etwas gesagt
aber wenn wir politisch diskutieren und
darüber sprechen wollen wie wir eine
bestimmte entwicklung beeinflussen
wollen dann sind es die bürgerinnen und
bürger die das tun das heißt es sind
immer die die gerade da sind die
eigentlich in der verantwortung stehen
diese veränderungsprozesse zu machen ich
finde ja den anderen super weil das wir
ist schlecht allgemein das stimmt immer
und deshalb ist mit wir immer gar keiner
gemeint das muss man konkretisieren
und so wie ich es machen will dass ich
sage ich lasse mich durch smartphones
nicht blöd machen
das kann nicht ganz konkret sagen sie
lassen sich blöd machen ich auch ich
hoffe nicht
also alle jetzt konkret dass ich würde
das natürlich wie wir hier sind
miteinander sprechen aber wir sind auch
eine demokratische gesellschaft wir
können wählen in der schweiz auch
abstimmen das heißt wir können aufträge
geben der politik das erwachen
als nächstes gibt es europa zu dem wir
leider nicht dazu gehören aber wir haben
immerhin über die datenschutz grund
verordnung gesprochen die ein punkt ist
als läge es gibt es internationale
politik wo handelspolitik beispielsweise
ausgehandelt wird wo es beispielsweise
darum gehen müsste diese rohstoff
geschichten zu lösen wir sind letztlich
die die politik mit legitimieren und wir
müssen einfach quasi das über alle
stufen so weit bringen das ist getan
wird und ich würde sagen die zeit
spricht eigentlich für uns das was sie
für die führen revolution und den
manchester kapitalismus gesagt haben das
wird den in den entwicklungsländern auch
kommen weil die auf dauer das auch nicht
machen können weil sie auf dauer auch
merken wir können diese dinge nicht mehr
verkaufen müssen nicht mehr legitimiert
so zu produzieren
es ist rufschädigend und der ruf hat in
dieser
welt in der so schnell überall
kommuniziert wird ein wahrer vorteil der
digitalisierung eben auch seinen typen
sie gehen ja ganz harten kritik mit den
politikern und politikerinnen also
dieses bild mit die dekorieren da die
liegestühle auf der titanic um das
stammt ja von ihnen und das bezieht sich
auf die politik in ihrem buch das
bezieht sich darauf die besten letzten
beiden wahlkämpfe in deutschland im
letzten wahlkampf haben wir versucht
eine obergrenze von 200.000 irgendwo zu
legitimieren obwohl wir wissen dass das
die große frage der migration nicht
durch eine zahl zu lösen ist und den im
wahlkampf vier jahre vorher haben wir
über ausländer maut diskutiert also über
die frage ob österreicher auf
bayerischen straßen maut zahlen sollen
oder nicht
das scheint offensichtlich die
hauptprobleme in unserem land zu sein
und nicht dass wir gerade dabei sind
einen menschheits ergreifende
strukturelle revolution zu erleben und
deswegen spreche ich vom umdekorieren
der liegestühle das gilt für die
klimafrage der wir tun wir tun so als
könnten wir ökologisch so weiter hausen
wie wir das bisher machen wir tun so als
wäre digitalisierung nur eine
effizienzsteigerung die wissen wir noch
schnell genug mitmachen oder dann wird
schon alles gut das ist das umdekorieren
der liegestühle das worüber wir hier am
tisch gesprochen haben was macht das mit
den menschen wie werden unsere
zukünftigen sozialen sicherungssysteme
aussagen was für eine art von
gesellschaft wird das sein wenn die
klassische arbeit von
leistungsgesellschaft wie wir sie bisher
kann nicht mehr den takt vorgibt das
sind alles dinge die jetzt in die
wahlprogramme gegossen werden müssen und
ich weiß jetzt es passiert ja hinter den
kulissen fanden die parteien plötzlich
an die ohren spitzt zu machen und jeder
der da als schall verstärker fungiert
jeder der diese forderung an die
politiker die er wählen möchte stellt
und sagt das ist eine antwort auf der
trägt zu einem bewusstseinswandel bei
und das ist dass wir es wäre das einfach
nicht so radikal sehen natürlich ist
quasi noch nicht alles gelöst was hier
vorstellen aber klimapolitik ist gibt
zahlreiche ab strengen anstrengen es
gibt ein pariser klimaabkommen das wurde
von jemanden gekündigt ja ok andere
halten sich dran und es wird sogar im
inland in den usa wird quasi dagegen
widerstand gemacht dass es gekündigt
wurde
wir sprechen in den sozialversicherungen
über anpassungen es geht um flexible
arbeitsverhältnis geht um jahres und so
weiter und so fort
wir können einfach nicht also was kann
man wolle nicht
das nicht wollen eine revolution
veranstalten weil damit einfach zu viel
kaputt geht von dem was sich bewährt hat
tatsächlich nun echt wirklich wie lieber
schritt für schritt machen aber es ist
macht das über die dinge die wir ein
händler das ist das ist ja begeistern
diskussion revolution steht ja nicht auf
der tagesordnung
jetzt bevorstehen ich möchte ja mal
nicht so stehen lassen schon gut
sozusagen von den gegebenen
verhältnissen hierzu diskutieren und
gucken welche entwicklungen spielen sich
da ab welche möchte man befördern welche
möchte man ihr blockieren
ich glaube dass das ist so eine so eine
perspektive die man dann reden anlegen
kann aber wir haben zum beispiel im
bereich der klimapolitik eine völlige
widerlegung dieser schritt für schritt
geschichte weil es passiert auf der
symbolischen ebene unfassbar viel tolle
pariser abkommen und dergleichen
wir haben aber jedes jahr steigende
emissionen und steigende einlagerung von
co2 in der atmosphäre kollege modeblatt
ifat ist gerade im sommer ein paar
interviews gesagt er hat die wahrheit
ausgesprochen es gibt keine
klimaschutzpolitik die empirie sagt es
einfach vollständig die emissionen
steigen also ist das was da läuft
offensichtlich nicht dazu angetan unser
problem zu lösen also muss man anfangen
anders darüber zu reden dass auch
radikaler zu betrachten des klimawandels
problems sind wir wieder ein wir müssen
miteinander reden was würde das denn
heißen kriegen verbieten preise erhöhen
ja warum möchte da müssen wir wirklich
hat dann müsste wird sich radikal werden
aber in den jahren doch einmal ran er
keine
man muss es doch erstmal es gibt doch
also bei freud heißt es den waren
erkennt nur der der ihn nicht teilt okay
und wir sind alles hat das smartphone
deshalb der verzicht auf das smartphone
er zucker also dass man über er auf
irgendetwas verzichten könnte was schon
mal in die welt gekommen ist ist ja
schon völlig undenkbare gedanke also ich
finde ich mit wahnsinnig gerne politisch
darüber diskutieren warum es in
zivilisierten ländern nicht möglich ist
autos zu verbieten die 600 ps haben
zweieinhalb tonnen wiegen
und durch innenstädte flügen als sei auf
der ganzen welt nur kabul
ja wo man irgendwie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
digitalisierung bringt nicht nur alle
lebensbereiche sie animiert auch dazu
alles miteinander eben verboten zu sehen
wie sich ja auch zu recht gesagt haben
aber wir sind am ende unseres
stammtisches wir müssen hier einen punkt
setzen zukunft ist nicht nur verheißen
sondern in erster linie einen
gestaltungsauftrag ich glaube das haben
wir an diesen stammtisch heute ganz klar
gesehen ganz ganz herzlichen dank fürs
diskutieren erbrecht gentinetta hält
vielen dank
[Applaus]
ja nächste woche spricht yves bost
anlässlich der baltus ausstellung im
berner museum in bonn über die neue
zensur debatte und zwar mit hanno
rauterberg einem kunstkritiker er
diskutiert mit ihm
ob man anstößige bilder abhängen soll
oder gedichte über malen und auch erst
klein stets um kunst und zwar um eine
performance künstlerin die sie
möglicherweise nicht kennen nämlich
umgetauscht sie ist 87 jahre alt und ein
film blickt gemeinsam mit ihr auf ihr
bewegtes leben zurück bleiben sie also
dran bank ist das interesse und eine
gute woche
[Musik]
[Applaus]